what you're about to watch is a clip
from my brand linux training where i get
together with entrepreneurs thought
leaders who want to build their brand
using youtube and making data driven
decisions to blow up their brand this
year
enjoy
the theme today was talking about what
to do when your channel is going down i
think it's helpful because at some point
everybody's channel
stops doing as well as it used to be
doing and so it's a good checklist to go
through so let me pop over
and share my screen
what to do when your channel
is going down and i'm gonna break this
up into two sections the first is like
er
which is you know you're having the
heart attack you just broke your leg you
got the concussion like you go into the
hospital like what do we do right now to
fix it and then more of the chronic
the chronic pain is like what's the
ongoing stuff that we can do to help
solve this problem for ourselves
unfortunately i've been called into a
lot of these situations for a lot of
big-name people who you would not expect
to be struggling and suffering and like
everybody else you kind of wish you had
more time than like this is happening
and blowing up my face right now what do
i do
um
but i'm going to give you some
strategies for both okay
and even if you haven't had a big depth
yet you can come back to this video and
use it as a framework to help you
see why your channel's not doing as well
as it should
uh okay so the first question i always
have to go in and find out
you know like if we're trying to
diagnose the situation right now alison
says can we use this strategy to get a
channel up and running uh yes especially
especially the chronic the chronic pain
stuff that we're going to get to in the
second part
um
but the first part the er is like
diagnosing hey where are we
have you done anything weird wrong
stupid or not and and that's usually the
first question right he's like did you
do something stupid
[Laughter]
oh you'd be surprised at the stupid
things people do to try to get their
channels going
or growing uh and be honest you know
this is where
especially you know in a group like this
or when you're bringing somebody in to
help you it's like hiding stuff is not
usually the best solution so we had we
had some people i remember had one guy
big name guy like somebody you'd
recognize who
uh bought a whole bunch of views from
reddit in argentina or something and
then the channel started to tank and
it's like did you do something stupid
man like what what what's going on
you're like no i don't think so like
okay cool and then you know you look at
the data it's like well what's this
going on here like oh yeah yeah we did
that
come on you just save our time a lot you
can get there a lot faster if you're
just kind of honest but did you do
something stupid did you did you buy
something you know did you buy a
guaranteed number of views or
subscribers
did you
just did you do something weird or off
and it's usually the first question
because i want to get that out of the
way um and the solution okay like stop
doing that right like stop buying views
from reddit in argentina and let's focus
on the fundamentals so we can get your
channel uh back up and going
okay second thing is don't panic
you probably didn't do something wrong
you know like unless you did something
stupid then you probably didn't do
something wrong and what usually happens
when you see a dip in
in
your channel is that
some of your best videos just fell out
of favor
what you'll usually find is you have a
couple videos that do well
it's it's not even 80 20 it's like 99
one
you know for the people here have been
around for a while you know you look at
pablo on this channel how many subs are
you right now pablo well 12 000. 12 000.
cool so so even on the channel like his
you'll see
there's like a couple videos that do
really really well yeah
and then most of them are just okay
so it's it's not 80 20 it's it's 99 one
or 99.9
and then you know 0.1
and so what often happens is if you see
it your channel dip is those top videos
fell out of favor
and so it's like not that youtube hates
you it's not that there's something
massively wrong don't panic don't freak
out just a few videos most likely fell
out of favor
if you didn't do something stupid
um nothing has really
nothing
has really changed
on youtube recently
um there's a lot of talk about instagram
recently we talked about it at brenda's
mastermind we're talking about this
morning in movie makers um on discord
instagram made a huge announcement
basically saying they're moving away
from pictures and towards videos
and the the ceo came out
a month or two ago talking about that
made a video on it uh and then a couple
days ago the kardashians started
freaking out this is not right you know
we need pictures
and it forced like the two kardashian
sisters forced
uh the ceo of instagram to make a video
response talking about where instagram
is going
and you can go watch it if you want but
basically it's we're moving away from
pictures and we're moving to video
which is great for us you know for you
guys here because you're making videos
pablo's very happy
right you take the video content you're
making on youtube and cut it up and put
it to instagram
they also announced that reels are not
just going to be 60 seconds but all
videos are basically going to become
reals now
uh so something big change on instagram
so if you're if your instagram account
is falling apart and all you're posting
is pictures that's a problem
because instagram has changed
but nothing has really changed in
youtube
so if your channel is falling apart you
see a big drop in views there's there's
nothing really that's going on on the
youtube side of things
so the next question becomes well did
you change something
right
so that's my next question people did
you
change anything
so did you change how frequently you're
posting did you change the format did
you did you introduce a new kind of show
did you change the length are you
talking about different topics now
um did you change your thumbnails up did
you add a new series did you use to
promote it in a different way that
you're not promoting anymore like did
you change anything
in your mark in your promotion strategy
for your videos because nothing in in
youtube has changed but did you change
anything on it
probably got a question on that
yeah um it's just a comment it's so true
and and you've been helping me analyze
my data
because when um when willis meet is mac
rock you know on on tv i did two videos
explaining the violence doesn't help you
know
and so my channel when it was a weekend
that it got a record you got a record
that video ago so it brought a lot of
people and all my
all my statistics
were because of that video so it helped
me a lot but when that video after the
28 day 30 days 60 days went away
you know now i i it looked like a my
channel is stanking it's going down you
know
i felt that so and one of your videos
you were explaining uh last time that we
do
news or we do what we really want to do
that bring us customers now that's
that's the
the do news or thing that is very
popular it's a lot of stress but um yeah
and so i i completely see that that pain
you know
yeah which leads to the next one which
is seasonality c
zonality you get that right yeah and
that's both for
uh both for your industry
and your videos
so
there may not be anything wrong it's
just it's seasonal
right so if pablo so pablo does
negotiation videos
so
that's not seasonal right i mean you'd
think people care about negotiating
all year long
but if he's talking about will smith
and the slap
that's uh it's already played out right
we're not going to be talking about will
smith in a slab i mean we've already
stopped talking about it but definitely
not in a year or two years or three
years so there's a there's a cycle to
that specific video
so
is your channel falling apart or losing
losing views compared to where it was
because of some kind of seasonality
in your type of video or the whole
industry as a whole so pablo his video
takes off amazing and then it starts to
tank cool we expect that
but it can be sad because you see your
channel all the numbers are negative
growth is going down like what happened
uh but this is where it's it's usually
much better to go after the more
evergreen stuff
than than trendy because
the trendy stuff you have to stay on top
constantly
so if you're gonna pick something that
is trendy at least try to have something
with a longer cycle
so
last time we talked about casey going in
doing amazon book reviews
the best ones that he can review are not
the ones that are
popping hard right now because a lot of
the books that hit the best seller list
right now
[Music]
they're gone in two weeks right the
authors like pump it hard and then
they're out the best ones for him to
look at are the ones that have been
consistently selling for years and will
probably continue to sell so i think we
looked at tim tim ferriss for work week
quickly
uh a couple weeks ago in case he's like
oh yeah that copy sucks
okay great i can fix that in a second
amazing
that's a great book to do because it's
been selling for years and will continue
to sell for years and so
those are the types of videos that we
want to be making if he was only looking
at the hottest ones right now then
the caveat is you have to keep making
more you're on the hamster wheel so
pablo you could if you wanted to keep
that trend going you could you just have
to be able to move to whatever the next
trend is right now
yeah
whether it's uh
something in politics
yeah yeah
they just mentioned just agreed to
something i'm canadian so i don't really
follow along with you guys
mention just agreed to pass the bill or
whatever right so so how do you
negotiate with mansion you know on on on
those things how do you negotiate with
putin how do you negotiate with trump
you know how
anything that's in the news cycle right
now
but
it will fall off in a couple weeks so
now we have to continue to stay on top
uh sir just says
seems like you're saying that
consistency is key with evergreen video
content [ __ ] current news help us
build our subs is that strategy doomed
for failure so it's not doomed for
failure
it just requires you to stay on the
hamster wheel
so if pablo was only talking about
whatever's on the front page
of the news cycle right now
then he would have to continue to make
the videos or his channel would fall
apart like great will smith it popped
and then now it's all negative for that
video right and and i guess it brought
the channel down a little bit but his
his consistent
his channel is in spanish and talks
about negotiation those things are going
to be
always valuable always helpful
um
he talks he talks about chris voss he
talks about never split the difference
it's still a book that's selling super
well so it's
if you're looking at the long term the
best strategy is the ongoing evergreen
the stuff that's going to live forever
if you want to add in current news
trending your opinion your thoughts that
can be a faster way to get out of the
gate so back to allison's question like
this will this help me get my channel up
and running like yeah doing new stuff
and trendy stuff can help you get an
influx of subscribers and views
it's just gonna have a really short
window
and the biggest advantage of youtube is
that your content lives forever
if you want to see this full video as
well as train live with me twice a month
to blow up your brand join the brand
linux training program there's a link to
join right there next to me continue to
believe i'll see you there